that
and not so much in the uk but certainly
in america it was
you didn't date somebody unless your dad
had
given him the once over
you know you just didn't
maybe you disagree are you saying that
sierra's dad wouldn't have approved a
future
i don't know maybe he would who knows
but but no i mean
in the states it was like the first
thing that happened there was a a trope
of you know the boyfriend knocking on
the front door and the father opened you
know um answering it
and
you know she's agonizing over oh i need
to make all these choices well the dad
used to do the first level of filtering
you know a few a couple of decades ago
there was also the fact that it's like
actually do you know what the idea of a
woman
finding a man's body attractive is
relatively new as well i mean i remember
i don't know when i was in my early 20s
maybe when women started started going
oh he's got a nice bum before that
it was of no
importance whatsoever whether a guy was
whether guy's body was sexually
attractive or not
so like did girls just not care about
looks at all it was more about character
it was much more about kind of because
women are supposed to be the attractive
ones yes it's certainly supposed to be
the moment yeah
let's face it we're not actually i mean
you know maybe
0.5 percent of men is really yeah women
find 80 of men unattractive yeah yeah
not just okay unattractive yeah yeah
yeah so yeah i mean that you know pretty
much pans out yeah but like just to to
your stat like all the people that i
know in relationships have all been from
like in work friend of a friend stuff
like that the tinder thing just hasn't
worked for guys by the way the tinder
thing just hasn't worked actually even
my female friends well yeah women women
only swipe right like 5 to 15 of the
time on dating apps and that's the
number one way people are meeting
nowadays so the reason that women say
things like men are trash is because
they're all screwing the same ones
i would say the only thing i don't agree
with that like a lot of it like made
sense the only thing is like when he
said what he looks for in a woman that
the the only thing is like i do want a
female i'm dating to at least have a job
because if she was 23 and didn't have a
job that would just be a little bit
weird and you you've got to take the
economic like
thing in this like the average wage is
like 28 grand right and and you can't
live off that on your own so usually you
expect you and your partner to have a
job so if she doesn't then all the
burdens on you so i just think
in modern day you kind of have to not
she doesn't have to be the provider but
you at least want her to bring
uh something
it probably mitigates risk a little bit
if people are more successful
but i think the point is like you're not
if a girl has a high paying job you're
not like oh that's hot yeah where if a
guy has a high paying job we're like oh
damn yeah yeah so that's more like a
minimum i at least want them to have a
job but i don't care if they're
a minimum i think it's worth it
could i just like interject that because
i think it's worth pointing out
that i mean so for instance
i lived in a house with one income my
father's income
my mum looked after me and my brother so
she could dedicate all of her time to us
yeah
feminism rolls along all of a sudden
it's better to have a boss than a
husband
you know that was basically the message
of feminism isn't it and uh and
basically
uh
families had two incomes
uh and the house prices and prices of
everything else rose to accommodate that
they got dinkies double income no kids
yeah
which which were like the uh the
you know newly married couple
and then and then essentially everything
everything became more difficult because
all of a sudden you needed two income
you needed two incomes to be able to get
a mortgage you needed two incomes to be
able to afford a holiday
um and that was the sum total of the
effect of of feminism other than the
fact that of course the government got
twice as much tax but tax money
you know
and the children got neglected as a
result
i think it also depends on the lifestyle
you want to like if you want to live in
a city like london yes two incomes is
necessary but if you want to live in a
rural side
where the home prices are significantly
cheaper
if perhaps you want to homeschool your
children grow your own food i think it's
definitely possible depending on what
your priorities are
um but yeah it depends on the couple
what did you guys think of the clip i
feel like those comments are based on
like basic gender roles like things are
not
it's it's not um it doesn't match what's
happening in today's world
um he's saying oh
women are only going for successful guys
but women have literally been taught
from a young age to go for a guy that's
stable that has a good job not just by
their mothers by their fathers too
because no dad would accept a guy who
doesn't have a [ __ ] together let's say
so well i think i think that women um
are told from a young age they don't
need a man
and you can you can be your own boss and
chase the bag
as well yeah yeah so i don't really find
the ends yeah yeah i don't really find
that like um
at least under a certain age i don't see
women chasing the guys with like
that are like driven and hardworking and
like good men i see them chasing more of
like the bad boys
yeah i think a lot of women or
these days now are going for a lot of
like image yeah guys that drive nice
cars guys
that have money and have maybe because
it's social media and this whole
thing of looking a certain way
um if you drive this you have this i
feel like women are now going for that
that's probably why they do end up
with men that are just [ __ ] because
these men don't actually have
personality it's just all the front
basically and they'll rather put up with
that if it means they're sitting in a
nice car and they're going to the nicest
restaurants like you said novakov
they'll rather put up with that then i
guess after bear meant that they'll
rather have that bare minimum if it
means that they look good doing it
but then also like pearl said like um
men are intimidated by successful women
so i didn't say they were intimidated no
they i'm not them all i don't know i
don't i don't think so i don't think
about care
i think they do a lot of men have this
ego thing i think they're only
intimidated by women that throw their
money in their face
so like i don't i don't think um like i
i don't think most men are intimidated
by women that have a lot of money it's
more the women that think they're better
than everyone else and it's not really
that they're intimidated they just don't
like them or want to deal with them
because they think they're better than
everyone else two two hundred thousand
dollar engagement ring
but yeah
but then don't the men carry themselves
like that as well when they have money
it's the same well i think they just
carry themselves like they're the prize
because they are
i think it definitely is ego they can
feel a bit intimidated you know if their
their wife is earning a lot of money and
then
she wants a certain thing and he can't
provide it for her that that could like
hit his ego and make him but i think i
think that's the point though like so a
girl will like the girl will don't
doesn't mind ego right if someone's
quite uh they're like confident stuff
like that shall we but then when a
female is very ego-driven right that's
off-putting to a lot of men because
that isn't you know like you said you
were like oh well why shouldn't i like
they've got money they've made their own
money and it's just like
we don't really care like like type
things so it's not a very mothery thing
to be yeah and it's not really don't
care because don't get me wrong like if
i had the same girl and one one earned
more and one earned less of course i'm
gonna go for the one who earned more but
that's not the that's not a deciding
like if you had a chart of like a game
chart with all these like stats that's
not the deciding factor is really low on
the scale
well i think it's because a lot of times
women like we think like women and so we
think that men want the things we want
but they just don't care
it's like it's it's like have you ever
had a guy have like a really cool shoe
collection
do you care
okay she cares
i think it was interesting i'm sorry too
um one one other thing that came up was
was that
you know it dawned upon me that
you know there are there are couples
where the uh where the the man's
successful and the woman isn't and there
are couples where both of them are
successful they're very very very few
uh couples where the woman's successful
and the husband isn't
you know there's a you know
there's this kind of
trope of the of the the power couple
but um
you know
it just very very seldom happens and the
relationship needs to be incredibly
strong to sustain that as well
would you guys um find a guy attractive
if he made less money than you
significantly
would that matter to you
not really to be honest i don't think
that equates to attraction yeah because
like yeah